[Music]
so one of the most powerful tools that
we discuss in the book is open questions
and what we mean by that is open
questions are those questions that you
possibly cannot know the answer to and
what this does is allow us to be
authentic many of us are trained in
asking leading questions meaning don't
you think that or if you had the choice
wouldn't you those are leading you or
prompting you into kind of a specific
answer and people feel that right away
they feel done too in kind of a whip a
strange way an open question is the
opposite you know it's a question that
again I couldn't possibly know the
answer to so it would be like what was
the most important Christmas or holiday
you remember growing up and why was that
you know it's that genuine curiosity in
which you're asking another person
question that they feel received and
they feel like there's something there
that you're really questing I mean it's
really interesting the root of the word
question is quest
I'm questing to learn more about you as
a person
we can't fake that nor should we and
this is so often forgotten especially
with those who are actually even close
to us family members we forget this very
innate ability we all have to be
genuinely very curious about one another
it's like the first time you fall in
love or the first time you met someone
you're really interested for the first
time you're so curious about them and
asking them open questions why did you
take that job that you did I'm so
curious to learn that it's that type of
questioning those are open questions and
never before has it been so difficult
we're very polarized in so many ways
right now so being at the dinner table
what I would offer is first spending
time before entering into family events
as what do you most want out of this and
I think if you can answer that question
truly from an authentic place it
often is an answer if I want connection
I want to spend time with my dad who you
know maybe he doesn't have you know 20
more Christmases who knows what it is
but being very very clear on your
intention for that family gathering
that's one second is using inquiry
styles to again create bridges you know
having political discussions or having
discussions about even sports teams can
often lead to heated places so
remembering your intention in that
moment and saying you know my intention
was to come here and connect with my
father my intention was to connect with
my mother-in-law if I asked her bridging
questions in that moment like what is
really important to you about the
holidays I'm really curious what would
what was it like for you as a child when
you met with your parents you know
trying to find anything that you can
that will help people relate to
experiences relate to times of strong
connection for them that will increase
the connection with our families and
again I go back to those three cardinal
rules you're not going to change another
person and you can't make them lover
like you and you can't necessarily even
make them see your perspective but you
certainly can respect them and respect
how you treat yourself and them in those
moments so moving to bridging questions
at least allow for a place of connection
during these really important holidays
[Music]
you